un mot mai prochain noël je trouve que
tu abordes le sujet vraiment de la bonne
manière cirque il faut rentrer dans les
solutions concrètes qui peuvent être
apportées exemple est dans la ligne de
ce que tu évoques il ya une procédure
sur le droit d'asile une personne peut
être débouté peut être ensuite à faire
appel une des propositions c'est qu'une
personne débouté soit pour le coup
automatiquement assigné à résidence
parce que je crois que ce qui était en
jeu dans cette affaire est d'une
certaine manière je serai aussi bien
d'accord avec brice qu'avec jean
dominique giuliani
c'est à la fois être capable de proposer
des mesures opérationnelles de les
mettre en oeuvre ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
skis depuis fort longtemps n'est pas le
cas et en même temps ne pas perdre nos
principes
la réalité du droit d'asile
c'est que une amélioration du
fonctionnement des différentes
administrations et aussi de la justice
quand elle a à connaître du droit
d'asile aujourd'hui permettrait de
traiter sans perdre nos principes
une bonne partie du problème est ce
qu'on est capable d'avoir un oeuf prat
plus efficace de rassembler les services
administratifs quant à koné du droit
d'asile au sein en france d'une agence
de l'asile d'être capable de rapprocher
le traitement des dossiers du terrain
c'est à dire d'avoir des antennes
locales et d'obliger l'ofpra avoir un
travail beaucoup plus local
d'appréhension et traitement du dossier
est ce qu'on est capable mais cette
affaire de de gestion de notre
administration généralement faut que les
politiques soient capables de donner une
obligation de résultat et de la sueur et
quand ils ont une mission
l'ofpra ça n'est pas une institution
libérale en apesanteur
je dis ça parce qu'un ami me disait
récemment avoir rencontré françois
hollande sur ce sujet et françois
hollande tient sur deux propositions qui
lui faisait lui répondais mais l'offre
bras voudra pas qu'elle lamentable aveux
de carence et d'absence de l'état si
l'état fait un choix politique marquée
de dire il y à un sombre de grands axes
sur l'efficacité la poussière
administrative sur sa rapidité sur la
vérification de la localisation des
personnes
la question l'assignation à résidence il
te fait essentiel
alors voici encore un état en france on
doit être capable d'assurer seul à cette
dimension paraît tout à fait essentiel
mais l'enjeu pour nous les amis
républicains c'est un parti de liberté
c'est de ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
c'est d'assumer qu'il y a en particulier
quand on est dans une situation de crise
comme celle d'aujourd'hui des progrès
urgentissime à faire dans le traitement
des procédures de l'asile et en même
temps de ne pas oublier que oui
l'asile fait partie des principes et des
valeurs de la république
l'asile fait partie des valeurs de la
république
non pas comme un droit créances c'est
sans doute la limite extrême par rapport
à la conception de 46 jean dominique
s'il n'y a pas de droits systématique à
l'asile car l'asile c'est ce que nous
proposons est ce que nous pouvons
proposer
il ya sans doute une ligne de crête très
importante entre le devoir d'asile
nous devons toujours nous poser la
question de ce que nous pouvons offrir
et de ce que nous devons offrir et ce
devoir fait partie des valeurs de la
république mais ce devoir ça n'est
évidemment pas l'automaticité et
l'inconditionnalité de la part d'une
personne ou d'une autre à réclamer ce
que la république ne pourrait pas offrir
mais cette question d'efficacité et
essentiel je la prolonge sur une autre
dimension car l'asile est à cet égard
très caractéristique de toute une part
de la gabegie et d'inefficacité des
systèmes publics français c'est le
terrain extrêmement délicat du public et
associatif
les associations qui interviennent dans
le domaine du droit d'asile sont pour
certaines d'entre elles efficaces pour
d'autres totalement consommatrices
d'argent public pour passer des messages
idéologiques et être en réalité très
éloigné de la solution du problème
il ya clairement un sombre de structures
qui font leur beurre à la fois du
malheur des gens et de l'argent public
mais ça c'est aussi affaire de
gouvernance aujourd'hui il ya rien à
attendre du gouvernement tel qu'il est
mais demain le jour nous serons aux
affaires
est ce que nous aurons ou non le courage
de dire y compris vis-à-vis de ces
structures là qui ne suffit pas d'être
une association lucrative sans but
pour émarger automatiquement à de
l'argent public et simultanément porter
des messages
je ne récuse pas le rôle de ces
associations françois noël
elles sont d'ailleurs indispensable car
il y a parallèlement un sombre de
structures très proche de milieux
religieux voire de milieux intégristes
qui sont aussi et nous le savons
aujourd'hui présentes sur le terrain
dans un certain nombre de d'endroits où
les personnes peuvent avoir recours à
elle il faut faire attention
l'efficacité de l'action publique c'est
que cet argent ne soit pas mal utilisé
mais que faute d'efficacité
d'association avec lesquels le ministère
l'intérieur travail messieurs les
ministres ce ne soit pas d'autres
structures bien moins recommandables en
terme de sécurité et d'ordre public qui
s'immisce est ce que tout ça est
insurmontable
la réponse est non est ce que tout ça
est idéologique
met en cause nos principes la réponse
est non alors c'est vrai que demander
une plus grande efficacité c'est pas un
grand moule idées politiques
et c'est pas absolument fondateur d'une
nouvelle idéologie de l'asile dans le
pas besoin de fonder tous les matins qui
entre on a besoin d'un système qui
fonctionne on a besoin comme l'a très
bien dit françois noël roger aussi
d'être capable véritablement face à des
flux considérable d'être capable de
renvoyer les personnes mais il faut le
faire avec un état qui fasse
véritablement entendre sa voix et qui
soit efficace dans sa mission merci à
hervé